you know it's been a little bit of time
now since the Dark Knight Rises came out
I think hopefully everyone's gotten over
their whatever their initial gut
reaction was we can all sit down and
talk about this like adults
because reactions that I've seen is when
we have buried wildly but pretty much
even on the people who liked it
everybody was a little bit disappointed
coming away from The Dark Knight into
the Dark Knight Rises everybody had a
little bit of mm I think it boils down
to one thing and one very specific thing
the Dark Knight
reset the rules here's the thing you
look at sort of the overall world feel
Dark Knight Rises doesn't really fit
with the Dark Knight
it fits much better with Batman Begins
and I'll give you a specific example one
of the things that there has been a
great deal of complaint and mockery
about is in the Dark Knight Rises the
entire police force is sent into the
sewers to go after Bane and so many
people have called the Gotham PD out on
that it's so stupid why would you send
every single cop who would ever do that
oh I don't know how about a police
department that's done it before the
Batman Begins the entire police force
it's sent into the Narrows in fact
Commissioner Loeb even tells Gordon
there's no one left to send they sent
everybody there so they've done this
before
but nobody called out Batman Begins for
this move but everybody called out The
Dark Knight Rises for it what changed
The Dark Knight happened in between
Batman Begins and The Dark Knight Rises
were both for lack of a better term more
comic book ish they were operating more
on those rules and it was fine with
Batman Begins cuz this was the reboot
this was setting what the rules were so
it could basically have them be whatever
it wanted now the Dark Knight didn't
abandon those rules but it made it much
more grounded in reality Batman Begins
good movie funny movie didn't feel
grounded in reality I mean a fear toxin
and the water main that's gonna disperse
into a gas into an entire city that that
is not a real-world issue a terrorist
blowing up crap that's a real-world
issue and that's ultimately what the
Joker was you really do feel watching
The Dark Knight that the Joker was
supposed to come back for the final
entry
I mean his line I thank you and I they
were supposed to still be going at it
and in fact a lot of aspects of Bane's
plan they feel a bit Joker ish don't
they I mean blowing out the bridges
isolating the city letting the citizens
of Gotham turn on each other does this
sound like anybody else we know I think
that's a holdover from ideas that would
have gone to the Joker had Heath Ledger
not died but he did die and we couldn't
bring back the Joker he can't recast him
not after that performance we can't get
a sequel to the Dark Knight so Dark
Knight Rises is really a sequel to
Batman Begins the problem is Batman
Begins isn't as good a movie but it's
the best one we could get under the
circumstances that I do believe I do
believe it is still a solid good finish
to the overall trilogy it's not a sequel
to The Dark Knight and sadly we're never
going to get that and on that depressing
little note this council is adjourned